coach-house the voice is surviving give
it a couple days I'm not gonna be asked
to sing the national anthem anytime soon
but it is awesome to be with you this
morning when did you know that maybe had
something special with this team in the
tournament probably when we went when we
won four more in Nashville to cut the
Nets down we had to go through Missouri
South Carolina Florida and then and then
Tennessee and you could tell that these
guys were fresh in March Tom Davis was
my mentor again and we always believed
in playing nine or ten guys if it made
for a healthier locker room but what's
really been interesting down the stretch
is when I'm tired I got two players my
backcourt Bryce Brown and Jared Harper
that played heavy minutes all year long
those guys would have an excuse but the
rest of the guys shared and so as a
result we're fresh here in April and
still playing yeah and you know what
Coach count John Calipari said prior to
the game hey the last time we met has
doesn't have any impact on this time
around it was really a smart coaching
move on his part because he wanted to a
say to his kids hey we might have blown
him out this is different but I do think
he really thought this is different they
weren't in sync
you had PJ Washington we weren't quite
sure how healthy was and you got to have
a style to be able to keep up with your
pace there and I'm sure that you got
their attention with what you guys did
to North Carolina if somebody hasn't
seen Auburn play how would you describe
it
we're dangerous because we put four guys
on the floor that if they can see it
from three they can make it and and and
so you just never know when that's going
to rise up and bite you
tal's right when we went to Lexington at
the end of February and lost by 27 a
couple things happened in number one
John told me after the game he said he
said coach that's about as good as we
can play any minute and I think he knew
going into this one you know guys we may
not shoot it
we shot it last time cuz Dan we didn't
play badly and we didn't let that that
that that abscess
we were we were dominated we didn't let
it define us we didn't let it
Carla saw that was the last game we lost
with Layton season at Kentucky so the
key is to not yeah we gave them the
credit and then we decide ok that's a
Final Four team we're not now what do we
need to do in this next month to try to
see if we can make a run and the kids
have done everything that was required
we're talking to Bruce Pearl joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive Continental as a tire for
you I'm telling you man I've got old
Cadillac Escalade you remember one of
those back in the day that with the rims
and stuff like that like that was a cat
daddy wait what year is it
what year is it I think it's like it
it's a I think it's like at 92 what
color it Stan I kind of liked him you
got white walls no I don't know where I
was I got black walls but there
Continentals and they're sweet and I
think hear that baby what's the best car
you ever owned first car was a 1972
Monte Carlo and I paid for it with the
money I made from shoveling snow cotton
grass and working for the water
department and that was the first no no
no mine was a 69 Volkswagen that had no
floorboard in the back so anybody who
sat in the back seat they had to have
their legs up the entire time it was
like the Flintstones
you as you might expect I didn't get a
lot of girls there was not what did you
say to chumma ki KEK when you came out
and he had been injured towards ACL he's
being wheeled out too
the bench you leaned in to start the
second half and you say something and
everybody starts laughing what did you
say because it felt like it was one of
those tense moments there that this poor
guys you know season's over well all
right one of humours teammates Malik
numbar knows how to find the camera even
better than his head coach okay and so
true so Malik like asked me before the
game he says coach can I wear too much
jersey in warmups
and of course my first reaction is man
Malik there you go
nobody finds the camera better than you
the camera
so anyways they will tune out and he
they I said I said Schumer you are
starting to act like Malik want that
camera all over you that's good that's
what got him a smile because he is the
last thing she would want is the camera
not cuz he can't handle it it's just
that he wants to give everybody else the
credit he is he's our most valuable
player he's our best player again he'd
have been a late first rounder this year
and so one of the reasons why I was
emotional after the game is because it's
probably gonna have to wait a year and
and he'll be fine he is a spectacular
kid a spectacular athlete I'm sorry the
country is not gonna get to see him play
because we're out there on the floor
Kansas in North Carolina and he was the
best player of the floor that nobody
heard about I also worry about you on
the sidelines coach I don't know if
you've ever been hooked up to a heart
monitor but I would be curious what your
EKG looks like during a game because
there's at one moment in that Kentucky
game where your sweat pouring off of you
you still got your tie tied all the way
to the top and it looks like you're
trying to defend one of the Kentucky
kids shooting a three
well somebody has to get a hand up I
worry about you I do you know I
appreciate that my friend listen I'm
that way in practice I'm that way for
Division two exhibition game and I and
I'm that way when we play Kentucky to go
to the Final Four so the kids never see
any different now when we get off the
floor it shuts down it's different but
we're gonna get between those lines okay
and they're gonna start the clock it's
time it's time and that's how I want my
team's to play they got to be able to
handle the coaching and handle the the
challenges that we put on them and and
I'll be part most three-pointers made
through the first four games of an NCAA
tournament this is all time the 2001
Duke team then the 2018 Villanova team
the 2019 Auburn team only to be
surpassed by this year's Purdue team
with Carson Edwards and you go back to
the number one team shooting threes 1990
Loyola Marymount how would they be today
coach if Loyola Marymount was playing
now with that style cuz they they were
so far Paul Westhead was so far ahead of
everybody with this yep yep well you
know what I remember Paul's team's very
very well and and you know Tom Davis
Paul Westhead those guys kind of grew up
in the East actually Tom was a
Midwestern guy but he coached at
Lafayette Coast at Boston College and
and course against those guys they were
ahead of their time
they were innovators and you know we've
been shooting the three ball a long time
when I was at Tennessee Chris Lofton you
know became the all-time greatest
3-point shooter until I can offer and
then Bryce Brown you know maybe has
surpassed him so it the inside 3 is the
best play in basketball the second-best
offensive play is a perimeter three and
and so listen we kentucky did a great
job of taking it away from us
as a result we had to get downhill and
get to the rim and Jared Harper Bryce
Brown made one on one place in space to
tell allow us to advance Virginia will
do the same thing down there they are I
think they're the I think team shoot 29%
from three against up
they've got links at almost every
position they got big long guards
they'll switch out some and and and and
we're gonna have to hope we make some
but if we don't you gotta find another
way to beat them you said this is back
in the early part of the season you just
lost a Duke and we had Jeon from Hawaii
and the Maui Invitational and you said
they're beatable because I think people
thought Dukes gonna go into Fiat and you
said no they're beatable and they don't
have a lot of depth what we later found
out is they didn't shoot well from the
line and they didn't shoot well from the
three-point line
is this a disappointing season at Duke
you know I'm a coach and so I've got to
give an answer from that perspective you
know when you are a number one seed when
you learn when you win 30-something
ballgames when you get to the Elite
Eight you know you can't we can't ever
call that a disappointing season the
issue with the disappointment Dan is
again taking advantage of the
opportunities when are we going to get
guys like you know Barrett and and and
cam reddish and Diane Williamson you
know maybe three to top-10 players to in
the top five players together again and
for those guys not to win a national
championship but I think we're seeing
that more often than not and you're
seeing teams with the more experienced
Texas Tech a lot of seniors Auburn our
guys have been here a while Briscoe
state you know when it comes right down
to it are able to win it at the end just
because of you know maybe it was
unfinished business from the year before
do Duke those kids work together the
year before they hadn't come close
sometimes and you look at this how many
times did you come close to winning a
championship and then the next year you
want it and that's what experience
brings and that's something that they
just
have any uh do you know off the top of
your head anybody more exciting in one
year in college basketball than Zion
Williamson not best I'm talking about
exciting has anybody been more exciting
than Zion this year no you know maybe my
first reaction was Shawn Kemp back when
he first played at Kentucky you could
just see what if what I want an
incredible athlete he was no Zion was
something and Dan let me tell you
something this system is not broke okay
Zion Williamson was a terrific athlete
from Spartanburg South Carolina that
hardly anybody knew about he goes to
Duke and he's placed college basketball
for four or five months and now he is
the number one player in the draft he is
going to be able to you know obviously
the the endorsements and the contracts
we've gotten to know him a little bit
more as a man not just a player don't
tell me that the time that he spent at
Duke figuring out how to do it the right
way the training that he got the
exposure got to those coaches didn't
help him be much more successful at the
next level and listen I'm all for kids
being able to go out of high school I'm
for the liberty and the freedoms of this
country absolutely but there's nothing
broke about our system having those kids
come to college for a year getting eight
that kid is going to be part of Duke
forever
he'll go to the NBA he'll come back and
get his degree he'll bring his family
back to to those games and he's got to
connect and he's much more ready now on
and off the court to be able to handle
the rigors of an NBA season the men in
the locker room as let him go be a boy
for another year and and learn how to be
a man and and so I just think our
system's not broke people made way too
much about the ills of the one-and-done
C in Minneapolis coach Congrats thank
you thank you dad appreciate it Bruce
Pearl Continental Tire Coaches Corner
got a lot of energy man I feel bad for
that suit that he wears feels like he's
gonna burst right out of it Continental
Tire the proud supporter of the damn pad
Trick show for more information on
Continental Tire no matter what you
drive where you drive how you drive
Continental Tire comm for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]